Horror Tat in Thailand Angriff auf einen
Kindergarten im Norden Thailands
mindestens 31 tote viele Kinder die
Bilder sind so schrecklich dass wir
Ihnen nicht alle Bilder von dort zeigen
wollen es herrscht immer noch absolutes
Chaos aber dass die erste Eindrücke von
dort und ganz schnell einmal in das Land
das soll der Täter gewesen sein der sich
offenbar der Arbeit auch erschossen hat
selber das Leben genommen hat nachdem er
dort 31 Menschen offenbar getötet hat
ganz schnell direkt nach Thailand nach
Bangkok zu unserem Journalisten Kollegen
freier Journalist Karl van den hole ich
grüße Sie herzlich dort nach Bangkok
schildern Sie uns einmal was sie wissen
über diese Tat so kurz danach
ja was im Moment bekannt ist ist leider
eine neue gesamte Opferzahl in Höhe von
36 Personen das hat die Polizei bekannt
gegeben darunter 24 Kinder aus diesem
Kindergarten das ist eine schrecklich
hohe Zahl was bekannt ist dass der Täter
nicht nur mit einer Schusswaffe sondern
auch mit Messer durch die Gegend
gelaufen ist er ist er konnte dann
flüchten mit einem weißen Pickup
hat ihn dann den später im Brand gesetzt
diesen Pickup die Polizei hat dann
versucht ihn weiter zu verfolgen hat ihn
dann zu Hause aufgefunden
und hat dann auch gesehen dass er seine
Frau seine Tochter seine kleine Tochter
und auch sich selbst umgebracht hat
was für schreckliche Details zur dieser
Tat in Thailand was sind für
Hintergründe bekannt über ein mögliches
Motiv für diese Wahnsinns tat
über das wirkliche Motiv ist im Moment
wenig bekannte Hintergrund das geht das
ist aber der dass er früher bei der
Polizei war und vor etwa einem Jahr dort
gefeuert wurde wegen
Drogenvergehen
ob diese Entlassung von der Polizei
jetzt direkt etwas mit der heutigen Tag
zu tun hat ist wirklich nicht bekannt
man rätselt jetzt noch was könnte da
Auslöser gewesen sein für eine so
schreckliche zarte Zahl an an
Opfern für so einer schreckliche Tat bei
dem man wirklich auf kleine Kinder
schießt und sieht halt glücklich
ermordet
36 tote nach aktuellem Stand 24 Kinder
darunter nach dieser schrecklichen Tat
in einer Kita im Norden Thailands und
das waren erste Informationen aus dem
Land direkt von unserem
Journalistenkollegen Carl van den hole
dort in Bangkok herzlichen Dank
[Musik]